حرب التكنولوجيا بين الولايات المتحده
والصين متواصله واخر فصولها يتعلق بحذر او
على الاقل تقييد تطبيق تيك توك جهود
التصدي لتهديدات التكنولوجيا الاجنبيه
وتحديدا الصينيه يقودها هذه المره عدوان
بمجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه حيث سيكشف
السيناتور الديمقراطيه
والجمهوري جون تيون عن مشروع القانون الذي
يحمل عنوان تقييد ظهور التهديدات الامنيه
التي تهدد تكنولوجيا المعلومات والاتصالات
التشريع وان تمريره سيتيح لاداره بايدن
سلطات جديده تمكنها من حظر تطبيق الفيديو
المملوك للصين وتطبيقات اخرى قد تشكل
مخاطر امنيه غير ان صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
استبعدت ان يكون حاضر التطبيق هو الهدف بل
ابقائه تحت اعين الحكومه فتطبيق تيك توك
الذي يستخدمه اكثر من 100 مليون امريكي
تعرض مشاهدينا لانتقادات متزايده بسبب
مخاوف من انتهاء مسار بيانات المستخدم في
ايدي الحكومه الصينيه البيت الابيض هنا من
جهته رفض الاعلان عن تاييده او عدم تاييده
لمشروع قانون مجلس الشيوخ وفقه ما ذكرته
ويذكر بان الصين منعت منذ فتره طويله
العديد من الخدمات الامريكيه عبر الانترنت
ابرزها نذكر جوجل متى
[موسيقى]